why would anybody be on ethereum if you
can
potentially hack it versus bitcoin yes
because you can do more complex things
you know on bitcoin you like do this
go there do that it's very simple but in
ethereum you can do anything you want
using any programming language you can
build a game you can build a lot of
stuff and this is essentially what we
now
know as smart contracts smart contract
is essentially a
unbreakable contract if the code is
correct an unbreakable contract is
between you and me so let's say
we have an agreement on a contract based
that you have to pay me every month now
you can break that contract but you
cannot break a smart contract i don't
need to trust a lawyer i don't need to
trust anybody because we both looked at
the code and the code says
you will send me on a specific day
specific amount of money and the code
cannot be changed
because code is on the blockchain so we
both trust that nobody on the blockchain
is gonna change
our agreement that piece of code that
simply says you
send money on the fifth of every month
to this wallet